what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here Amy castle to the left of me right
here you're right I think do you
consider yourself brave I would say so
yes
I wouldn't I think you're a total wimp
okay but these firefighters are brave
I'm gonna be checking out the trailer
with you today for only the brave this
is from the screenwriter of the latest
Transformers movie so you know the
script is solid it's from the director
of Tron Legacy and oblivion two sci-fi
movies and I guess this is his venture
into true story territory I'm excited
for this trailer because there's a lot
of famous actors in here such as you
know Jennifer Connelly yes Taylor Kitsch
Josh Brolin Taylor John and I do it all
the time my voices now there's a lot of
flames and I'm not you asked me if I was
brave I love them that bridge I'm that
brave are you now we just switched let's
do a shout out today for Andrew Hayes
the bravest man I gaze Andrew with
trailer for injury everywhere and then
charging out of these planes Wow
comes just bare on the fire it was the
most beautiful and terrible thing I've
ever seen whoa that's efficient value
I heard you guys had some slots
available you doing here I just had a
daughter and I just really want to get
her what I never had if you give me a
chance on the way down
the difference between time to crew and
hotshots yes sir
hotshots are on the front line and they
get to engage the fire directly you guys
have type two so why didn't you do what
you do best
stay in the back and our [ __ ] man
they're gonna become hotshots right
[Music]
trained for over four years at all hours
all of our qualifications
sooner or later fire is going to come
knocking in our hometown but until we're
certified my crew won't even be able to
set foot on the line doing something
that hadn't been done before it takes
time it's not easy man until the Braves
in this beautiful Vista because once
you're hot jobs whoa oh man past our
line it goes to our town
this really happened what you hear
[Music]
no one could be prouder of his boys than
I am of you guys oh I caught a trailer
for this movie before American assassin
that was different it was the second
trailer I think yeah it was like
rock-and-roll badass that firefighters
fighting the fire and I was like this
looks cheesy and this trailer this looks
like a really interesting drama oh that
was a really good trailer yeah way they
built that with music and just the whole
storytelling so it looks like it could
be a powerful piece of material I'm
hoping so yeah I'm hoping so I've never
even heard of where was this granted
Montana yeah I mean I like stories of
firefighters yeah when I was young
there's the only other profession I ever
actually yeah being in seventh grade and
going to the library and I like to check
it out two books on firefighters I could
have been one of these guys but instead
I watch trailers yeah you know it's just
as important and different when 9/11
happened needed to be someone hey what a
cast - it's a powerful cam miles teller
and Josh Brolin and Jennifer Connelly as
the a concerned wife he always got to
have the concern supportive why me the
concern and a lot of the time too you
know firefighters they're not fighting
crazy fires all the time I mean we live
in LA and we just had a pretty big fire
Burbank
yeah few weeks ago I really hope this
trailer is conveying what the movies
that because the other trailer is so
different and this trailer that it looks
like it's about the relationships that
firefighters form the bond and the
relationships they have with the fire
how it's beautiful but terrifying at the
same time that bear in the beginning
yeah I mean and then the end the the
helicopter shot their own shot with the
deer running on the mountain was yeah
it's beautiful and I went to Colorado
recently and they were affected by a
fire not long ago - it's heartbreaking
when you see like whoa so much of nature
has been destroyed by this fire and
people
their lives in danger because houses get
burned down and everything it's a really
scary situation of being for so long too
when you're fighting that line you're on
the line I mean even if from the fire we
had here recently hours and hours and
hours and the same team with those
extreme conditions of the heat and
exhaustion the first big firecracker
movie I saw was backdraft I've heard
it's very unrealistic to her to what her
money's actually like and then I heard
one that was pretty accurate was this
movie called ladder 49 with Joaquin
Phoenix and a lot of times you know like
they they try to hone in on like back
trapped I felt was really about the
making the fire seem like an enemy and
cool and matter 14 I was more about the
relationships and bond
I'm hoping this movie can be a good
hybrid of that because this is a pretty
devastating thing they have an epic
Hollywood scale so I'm really hoping
that this film can take the opportunity
to provide both of strong character
dynamics strong motivation relationships
and it was cool spectacle with this true
story of this crazy-ass fire it looks
like they're gonna tell a story in a
really cinematic way and also hopefully
be truthful to the character I hope so I
don't think I could have fought the fire
I probably could have you could have
yeah you just say you couldn't have
things could have well I be that guy
flopping be the flip-flopping you are
the flip flop all right team I'm gonna
I'm gonna hang back here very
comfortable with sweating I don't
perform at my best when I sweat I'd be a
great firefighter and making excuses
contributing respect firefighters I want
yeah yeah I once went to a firefighting
station and they let me try on the
outfit and everybody was heavy so heavy
and I was like it was a real turnoff I
cannot slum that much weight around on
my person you're carrying so much extra
would be extra pounds like 40 pounds why
why just as I'd say you don't get burned
I'm glad we have people like this I'm
glad we have like actual brave heroes
like this yeah I got a ball like the law
enforcement stories or military stories
for some reason the one that's always
connected with me as firefighting tales
so I'm hoping this trailer conveys what
what it is they're truly going for here
my concern is this director is movies
like oblivion and Tron Legacy are more
about spectacle and don't really use
such as they're good but they're not
great maybe he knows this and he's like
I want to turn that around yeah yeah yes
that's what I'm hoping for that he can
show he could do something on a smaller
scale I mean it's a huge fire but it
looks like it's a dial back scale it's
not sci-fi sure all right well before we
wrap this up patron today shout out for
Andrew Hayes Andrew Hayes is his 21 year
old man who lives in New Jersey he has a
YouTube channel where he does movie
reviews if I were to take the title of
only the brave I would put it towards
Andrew Hayes cuz this guy can approach
any woman he's ever wanted really yeah
it's a skill I've harnessed and I'm so
good at and I taught him how to do
Andrew Hayes share your secret and it's
really what it is is he's just so
good-looking
that he can get any girl he wants that's
a helpful it's Trey it's the easiest
thing see guys like me I have to work to
talk to a woman cuz I'm not I don't
naturally look like Andrew Hayes all
andrew has to do is go hi and somehow
they are all on top of him and Andrew I
hate you for that because you're not
actually brave I'm brave he's bright now
you're back to being brave I'm ver a
flip-flopper I've soldered on that
firefighter man on that fire fire you're
on fire I'm like a last minute motivated
kind of guy at least better late than
never but Andrew you keep up that bridge
there's been no consistency in anything
I've said a lot of nonsense I'm spewing
out right thanks for tuning and you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell follow Amy castle it's
Amy castle on Instagram Twitter and most
importantly
- and I'm hoping that the bar at the
bottom is cutting off my face and all
you see is my hair you like that don't
you you know like that
[Music]